alex go
okay let's go alex
so the first two moves are good but then
we play something
creative okay let's play
some gambit probably everyone knows this
gambit right now yeah because i think
they both played it against kayaking uh
yeah actually it was
played before for quite some time but
i mean why not
to follow the footsteps all the greatest
players
especially in such an important game
yeah this is a good move
well here i'm a little bit confused
because
frankly speaking i don't remember what
am i supposed to do here
do i think on g7 or not do i play e4
or not and i think it was like
this move and this move
i hope so
i think it was one other twice as white
maybe now queen e7 is just good ah no b5
first of course if i was
if i was removed to make um to be played
first
because now queen is on check is very
annoying and then black is just
massively better
okay but then i just lose and i quickly
start the next game
which is also perfectly fine
yeah let's retreat uh but this is going
uh very wrong for me
okay let's check the pawn and then we
should be free then knight d2 then i
didn't know then i don't know and maybe
i developed
and miraculously make a draw that's what
chronic say
also bishop be free was the idea maybe
now
well why didn't i go for bishop e3
because i'm dumb
bishop g4
uh do i play just a free now yeah i
think i can i should play a free
whoa that's harsh
if i if i take he goes work with queen
of six check i guess
and that's his brilliant idea
so what else can i do maybe we can just
take like anyway just take
okay so let him shine i mean i have
nothing uh i have nothing to get someone
crushing me
in a bunch of bleach ah
that's just it yeah that's just it
very smart very smart
okay but at least i kept
this pawn on on g7 so i'm
reasonably happy
i'm just kidding of course i'm not but
uh
okay what to do this guy is just playing
too good
probably as good as mr stockfish would
play
or even better
so what do i do now like rook c100
screen b to check okay this is basically
lost in
either way
so i don't know let's go this one
[Music]
let's go this one
now this is just class
very classy player
i can't do much
i wonder if i deserve a chance in this
game
he probably thinks that i do not deserve
anything yeah
but now i have a bishop for for a queen
so that's also fine
i guess i should retreat
oh
such a high level player yeah just
just a beast
i know i never had a chance in this game
i should say
never ever came close
to having a chance of competing with
such a beast
[Music]
all right congrats if i only knew
this is the players of such caliber i
would do something different